quand les cheveux sont bien du drap t il
son léger comme l'air voici donc ce
cidre alléger les formules d'hydra léger
avec minéraux les fonds marins minéraux
venue des fonds marins pretium en fait
c'est mystérieux minéraux sonic du sel
de mer nous disent les deux chimistes
que nous avons consultés et est peu de
sel de mer il se retrouve d'ailleurs
dans les tous derniers ingrédients en
plus du sel de mer il y a du bon vieux
c'est l'ordinaire
beaucoup plus qu'une celle de maire on
en retrouve dans presque tous les
shampooings ça rend le produit plus
épais et plus visqueux mais ça n'a aucun
effet sur les cheveux procure jusqu'à
80% et l'hydratation sans alourdir les
cheveux 80 % + d'hydratation
mais par rapport à quoi la réponse est
ici pour avoir jusqu'à 80 % +
d'hydratation vous devez utiliser ce
shampooing avec un revitalisant rien de
nouveau sous le soleil c'est vrai pour
la majorité des shampoings mon nexus
hydra léger élever votre nord bref une
bien belle pub est trop long